tokio la ciudad que nunca duerme a pesar
de estar en estado de emergencia
es hora de irse a casa por favor vayan a
casa
los japoneses ignoran las restricciones
impuestas por el gobierno especialmente
en cauca un distrito caracterizado por
su oferta de entretenimiento corona la
gente ha soportado mucho durante el
estado de emergencia a pesar de que se
ha aplicado varias veces yo siento que
todo el mundo ha sido como decir
reprimido y ahora quiere salir y
relajarse mata o te mata kings y el
incremento de contagios llevó a que se
prohíbe el público en la mayoría de
sedes de los juegos olímpicos' seis
prefecturas incluyendo tokio están en
estado de emergencia hasta el 31 de
agosto y en 8 regiones se ha elevado el
nivel de alerta sanitaria y aunque los
bares y restaurantes deben cerrar a las
8 de la noche y no están autorizados a
servir alcohol no todos cumplen con las
normas pueden ser multados con 2.700
dólares americanos a parís porque hay
tiendas y restaurantes que necesitan
trabajar para sacar adelante sus
negocios así que por eso pienso que está
bien que abran siempre y cuando tomen
las medidas sanitarias
no
[Música]
el jueves se reportaron 15.000 nuevos
contagios en un solo día cifra récord
está en este país desde que inició la
pandemia en la que más de 5 mil se
atribuyen a tokio con lo que japón ya
supera la barrera del millón de casos